all right so I am on my way to pick up
Isaac
today is January 10 Isaac's birthday's
on January 12
and so the today is Sunday and we've
chosen today to be the day that we go
celebrate Isaac's birthday and he
doesn't know it yet but we're gonna
Surprise them with a Knott's Berry Farm
a day a day at Knott's Berry Farm yes he
loves going to theme parks even though
he's still kind of afraid of roller
coasters that has a Down he still hasn't
gotten over that fear and he hasn't
really explored roller coach all that
much but he I think he just loves being
in the environment of a theme park which
is partially finding his I think I was
like that to know the kiddos I was
petrified by my rides for the most part
but I liked being at the theme park do
you get your money's worth probably not
do you have fun yes as a memorable yes
so we're doing that and we're going to
be inviting a few friends out today and
surprising Isaac with a birthday bash
hello Isaac what you got there your hand
conversing cough medicine you've been
sick how long you've been sick for four
look tired you just wake up yeah yeah
you're ready to do some fun stuff today
like stay home all day that's not fun
what's fun then where you looking at big
building that's your favorite stuff to
do it's going out to see stuff did you
brush your teeth yet
I wanna brush your teeth I didn't brush
my teeth eh either I just woke up and I
said hey I'm gonna go pick up Isaac
right now hey guys so put the birthday
boy over there he's way over there so he
doesn't know but let's hide these I
didn't expect present uh yeah I guess
no he doesn't know I don't even bring up
his birthday just we're all gonna go
somewhere together what you guys done
what a plane and eating at the same time
Oh laser blaster was the most powerful
weapon he has FEMA
are we going would you just call me
sweet its you going there next weekend
you know what gambling is oh you're in
for a treat then I'll let your dad
explain it all right we are on our way
we're in the car we are on our way where
I wish buddy where I mean in like two
years
no really we went to Tokyo Disneyland
right that doesn't count early you've
just been there where else do you think
we're gonna go oh I want to go to see
what why do you think we're going to
places like that I know maybe we're just
going to get some food right now I
didn't know it was our meeting up David
yeah they were just like y'all like it
you're like that is a no like to finally
be revealed where we're going I don't
know what that we're gonna eat and I
don't care where we go no I do now yes
awesome really good
you really have medieval times around
here I always wanted to go there but
guess where we're going
ah we're not going there you know they
also have a pirate show around here
excitatory whipping you mind is lovely
like cool I think we're ready to let you
know where we're going now you want to
try to get safe yeah yeah I'm not
playing with you this time are you
excited baby thank you please
no I promise you I'm not playing we're
going to Knott's Berry Farm all day
today we're going to spend the day and
not spray from celebrating your birthday
look at that what is that - ah yeah not
very fun why don't you want to go on a
ride I do want to go and ride but I'm
back in all this what if David gets on
one of them will you the David gets on
one that means do you have to get on
with you know what happened in Japan who
was talking to smack true
David's a baby
better watch hell am i stalking the
stomach face right now he's like already
done our stairs are we gonna be like
Isaac's a baby
and if David goes on one then with the
words that make you happy birthday ish
my Jimmy I'm right here
sarcastic much I know do you deserve us
laughing thanks for that city it's my
birthday today today is Sunday and Paul
you guys are having two different
conversations though I am tall so what's
your favorite thing to do at Knott's
Berry Farm Isaac you don't like doing
anything
JT you're a little sarcastic mood now
you see what you're doing you rub off on
the kid sorry wait a second
sorry controlling family help you like
yeah we were trolling him earlier ever
getting it we're getting the heart
return of it kinda get revenge
hahahaha where'd he get revenge okay
let's go back home are by Isaac
all right we are still waiting for David
and Julia to arrive and so we will eat
first and we do all he had to guess when
was the last time Jada to get to Friday
bezel eight years old I used to frequent
to you gift quite a bit back the day as
a high school student not so much
anymore
she's freaking to you very much often
you know what I think is this might be
my second time I've ever been really
yeah I think I am I came the ticket it
was back in 2009 you're the baby cray
cray when I came here I brought him in
his actual oh my baby baby until he's
turning eight years Oh Toby oh all right
a food just arrived
oh yeah Julia is here all Leighton stuff
oh good
ain't nothing important today other than
his birthday how's your birthday burger
good
oh you haven't tried it yet no how's
your birthday that's good what is that
birthday with a better birthday burger
that's uh Julie's under the sea in a
pineapple bi-metal and you got Krabby
Patties over there was that intentional
with the pineapple you think I don't
know
oh we're talking with your mouth full my
chinos
Cochino
every time I call him look go Tina we're
in Spanish means like a dirty guy he
thinks it's go t know maybe like go Tina
go and I'm like nah go Tina yeah
what's the first way we're going to do
this one
feeling funny getting to be a big boy
you don't do people rights
in Thailand big boy rides you want Isaac
the try a grown-up ride today that would
make me very proud
but I don't blame him if he doesn't want
to cuz
all we need
up until I was 9 years old my first
right he's about to behave so it's still
forgivable if he's still scared
I know Canada right behind me
you
come on guys ferrets mail
Isaac you show keep Davis and words of
encouragement you gotta give some
confidence okay
you can do it yellow shrine - I had
teachers like positive reinforcement
alright so for those of you guys that
are familiar was not very farm not very
far is a theme park located out here
SoCal and I'm pretty much a cannon I'm
it's like the
like all the people are here fun
oh okay
I shoulda shot in slow-motion look so
funny
no I shot it regular trying to convince
I'd like to get this rifle Jaguar and it
looks crazy to the track
for this one he's like I think I can do
this one I'm like cool now we're just
gonna convince Isaac but now he doesn't
wanna do
getting older you gotta go awesome
nervous a little bit
be okay it's a pretty slow ride compared
to the other ones we've been riding you
think you'll like it
I easily how was it
but first one I told you goodness a so
what is your favorite ride so far and
this was your favorite ride mommy knows
best right
I told him of my con I think when have I
ever liked
the position that you were going to get
hurt
fine I think I'm like you see it wasn't
it funny he's like silly mommy do we
have to get off let's do this again I
want to write it again I'm like oh oh is
it
Terrell Isaac law there was no thing
when you're above 6 feet above the ride
so for me it feels like a falling out so
when I realized that I sat down and like
these were a lot like no no no no no no
no forget it killed it build a falling
out come to top-heavy and does feel that
way then tracks are very narrow so shoe
fat then we'll go all the way down so
there's this big gap like this big so
the only thing holding me up is this
nylon strap and there's a little rusty
belt buckle
oh yeah
I'll even David yeah I get so worked up
comedy
I
a magazine you
you looked out of this one but now you
actually want to ride it oh he knows he
can't write I want to sure
you
enjoying marriage with Larry hey we have
a run over here buddy
unexpected date night on my birthday
yeah all right
I you say crunchy in Spanish Oh mucho
crunchy Ocho punch is gonna borrow the
word for crunchy and Chinese is tight
smooth so much easier than for at all
you know really is direct approach it
amuses your yeah what about the ball oh
girl
partying with the girls yeah so Isaac
can't make this right is the accelerator
and aunt decided to stay behind with
Isaac holy [ __ ] this mess
and in a night with something crazy
pretty nervous about this right because
it takes off like at a hundred miles an
hour right off the bat I'm gonna show
you what it looks like on takeoff Isaac
majority losing on all the right than
you
I think by the end of the day you know
change
which way would it end teach you about
boo-boo
Bron James project what team is you play
for carnivores no panda born and of ores
all right we finish our last Friday
night and I look perfect last right - it
was the last year the last two rides are
pretty all-electric Thanks
I think it was a pretty successful night
you know I forgot his birthday right and
like it's fun and then we have the
adults we got our fun and stuff that's
pretty fun for some these guys right
here I've been waiting for you
they've been waiting for you
all right so I think that's a wrap for
the night I think it's at the tip if
we're gonna do any more birthday
shenanigans later tonight no we're gonna
save it till Tuesday on his actual
birthday fair all right so that's a wrap
for tonight then not very far good night
to you not very far good night good
night
I beg you to come happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear happy birthday to you muchacha